c'est sûr il n'y aura plus de géant dans
la course transatlantique en solitaire
c'est ce que vient de décider
l'organisateur anglais ça signifie que
si les règlements de la prochaine course
avaient été appliqués cet été pas plus
de 18,50 Alain Cola n'aurait pas eu le
droit de se présenter au départ pas plus
d'ailleurs qu'Eric tabarli faucogniier
et d'autres favoris de la course ce qui
paraît étrange c'est qu'ins tous les
Français qui avaient une chance auraient
été éliminés alors il y aurait-il
absence de fairplay des Français se sont
presque aussitôt décidés à organiser une
course
parallèle décision raisonnable peut-être
mais l'intérêt principal de la transade
c'était justement d'être une course à
part un peu folle et c'est ce qui
faisait son succès l'Atlantique un homme
un bateau au départ l'idée d'un colonel
anglais Blondy hler à la première
édition en 1960 cinq concurrents en 1976
près de 150 la simplicité du règlement
de cette course lui avait amené le
succès populaire ce que n'ont jamais
connu d'autres épreuves de
voile moins de
18,50 en 1980 ça vous intéresse alin
Cola pas beaucoup moi ce qui me
passionne c'est c'est les c'est les gros
bateaux parce que ça présente un
engagement physique un engagement
sportif très important et puis aussi
parce que c'est la voix du progrès ce se
brider à l'intérieur d'une règle bon ben
c'est ce qu'on fait volontiers dans le
yoting traditionnel dans les mil une
courses qu'il y a de par le monde au
cours du programme de l'année cette
épreuve là était l'unique occasion de
développer des prototypes on la supprime
c'est un peu comme si dans le sport
automobile on supprimait la Formule 1 en
24 heur du main les Anglais ont la
réputation d'être sportif aussi cette
nouvelle réglementation ne peut-être
imputée au fait que la transate est la
seule épreuve de voile où ils sont
dominés par les Français le trop grand
nombre peut-être mais dans l'édition 76
les deux navigateurs disparus en mer
étaient deux marins confirmés alors et
bien ce sont les Français qui vont
peut-être prendre l'idée d'assler ainsi
Michel Etevenon qui a déjà participé au
financement de nombreux voiliers de
coursees depuis 6 mois des organismes
m'avaient demandé de me pencher sur
l'organisation d'une grande course
française et j'hésitais beaucoup à
passer de l'autre côté mais l'intérêt du
public allant toujours vers ceux qui
innovent et qui vont de l'avant je
n'hésite plus je vais m'employer
désormais à tenter de mettre sur pied
l'organisation pour novembre
1978 d'une course transatlantique
réservée au bateau par exemple à partir
de 31 de 18,50 et où seul le moteur sera
interdit elle partira de France elle
partira de France mais nos amis
britanniques ils seront bien entendus et
bienvenus dans la transate anglaise de
1980 la compétition sera sans doute
moins inégal plus d'excès les bateaux
seront très proches les uns des autres
moins nombreux au départ mais est-ce
suffisant cette année dernier ce n'est
pas le plus gros qui a gagné c'est Tabar
avec les 20 m de pwix et le deè n'était
autre qu'un modeste tri Marant de 9 M5
la largeur du 4 d'alin la M égalise
souvent les chances et dans une épr
solitaire comme la trans elle fait la
différence